some people love getting noticed
for me i'm like well all eyes are on
claire crawley
the bachelorette was spotted for the
first time since news broke earlier this
month that tasha adams is replacing her
on the abc hit show
this is insane what's more insane
the location where claire was spotted at
the exclusive photos obtained by et
show clara get this la quinta resort and
club near palm springs california
um i'm sorry say that again you know the
same location where the bachelorette has
been filming since last month
so could this mean that claire is
returning
that's the question or has she simply
been there the whole time even after the
show shake up
i don't know it's unclear but here's
what we know
let's take a look a source told et
earlier this month that claire's time as
bachelorette came to an end
after she fell for one of her men but
filming didn't stop
the source added that producers are
always embracing twists
turns and new stories and that anything
can happen
full of shocking surprises in one photo
claire is seen with her dog
honey but this is where it gets
confusing the 39 year old reality star
is spotted walking with a man and woman
we're not sure if they are part of the
show crew or if the man is a contestant
but in all bachelor history
the lead and the cast are usually
released from production
when their time on the series has come
to an end
[Music]
meanwhile abc has been teasing claire's
season on social
media still showcasing her as the
bachelorette
[Music]
in one promo the hair stylist is holding
up a pair of on-brand stilettos
while another video features claire
tossing a rose at the camera
this is surreal former bachelor nick
viall
is pretty much all of us dropping a
comment that says
i have questions i try to pretend i
don't care but
inside you know a source told et that
claire left on good terms with producers
her journey to find love will still very
much be shown on tv
but the question now is whether her
journey is 100
over i mean we shall see right
the bachelorette premieres this fall on
[Music]
abc